so the official word is the indictment
will be coming down tomorrow but Donald
Trump will not be arraigned until next
week we don't know exactly if that means
anything for now it could just be rumors
but the reporting coming from The Daily
Mail is that the indictment is expected
tomorrow and I believe this actually
comes from a report uh or I should say
it additionally comes from report from
it may have been Business Insider I'm
not entirely sure but I had seen early
reporting that they were still doing
some witness testimony and that the
final decision will be tomorrow and the
expectation is Donald Trump will be
indicted
but who knows who knows the the more
interesting thing about it is that if he
is indicted tomorrow did you guys know
that tomorrow's national Donald day I'm
seeing this a sovereign bra on on
Twitter tweeted this or he retweeted
someone else who had tweeted it that uh
March 22nd is National Donald day and
there's a whole bunch of other weird
things they're posting about March 22nd
322 and you can Google it and look at
all the weird I don't know apocalyptic
garbage nonsense well we'll talk about
that that uh um because it is
interesting and then we got more
information on the banks that uh are
imploding because this morning you get
First Republic one of the banks that's
expected to collapse and everyone's
cheering saying look it rallied 30
points and then after market it drops
10. so so it was up 30 and then it went
all the way back down 10 so what does
that put at minus 40 yeah the banks
ain't doing too well so uh well there's
that I guess but maybe we'll be okay
maybe everything will be just fine so
before we get started talking about all
that head over to timcast.com go to the
menu and click that join us button to
become a member and support our work
directly we're gonna have a members only
live show at about 10 10 p.m tonight you
don't want to miss it because we do now
have the call-ins set up so if you want
to submit a question and actually call
into the after show to hang out with us
and ask something of us or our guests
become a member at timcast and uh join
our Discord where we have we have a
system set up where you can submit a
question and then we're going to be
pulling people into a voice room to talk
during the Live members only uncensored
show so that that's going to be really
fantastic so uh that's a good reason to
be a member right also if you go to
trashouserecords.com you can pre-order
on Amazon the new song We're releasing
on Friday bright eyes and uh look the
last we've really least three songs
they've all charted on Billboard they're
clearly very upset with us because
bandcamp deleted our account and the
music associated with it because I will
tell you look a lot of people are saying
you know Tim Needs to build more culture
we're starting where we can weren't the
biggest company in the world so we we've
done some things one of those things is
you know Shane Cashman has a book tells
the inverted world he has two books now
and then we have music that we've put
out and uh I suppose it's so threatening
that despite the fact that none of the
music in any way is political or I
should say the song genocide was only
peripherally uh political we don't
directly address anyone by name or
anything they deleted our account so
clearly whatever we're doing there is
working and they're very threatened that
all of our songs have hit billboard so
that's why we're doing pre-orders right
now because if we do even better I would
like to well maybe y'all would like to
rub it in the faces of those who are
trying to tear us down because they
don't want us to have an impact on
culture so this song is coming out on
the 24th we then have a week to try and
get as many sales and downloads as
possible so we can once again hit
billboard apparently it's working so I
really do appreciate all of your support
that's trashouserecords.com but don't
forget to also smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about all of this and a whole lot
more is rep Troy nails
good afternoon Tim everything is well
bright eyes I need to know who wrote it
I did you did yeah give me give me a
line or two out of it uh uh I a lot of
people have to pre-order it okay all
right maybe we'll play it we have a
video with uh oh okay I'll play this
is the sound gonna play I guess
oh the audience I said there you go can
you hear it yeah
[Music]
I love the region
all right there you go coming out Friday
Hannah is that you in the background
doing the who absolutely not if I was
singing everyone would go deaf
unfortunately yeah yeah I think that's
Carter I want to thank you for having me
back I enjoyed my time oh yeah
absolutely it's good to be back here and
it so much to talk about Tim so many
things going on yes where's that where's
that bucket did you oh no so uh you're a
member of Congress and you have a book
called The Big fraud and there's a
picture of you in the in the Capitol
building on January 6. I think it's uh
uh perfect timing actually with the
potential indictment I guess I think
it's gonna happen but you here with your
book talking about well the the fraud
yeah the last time I was on your show we
were talking about it it wasn't released
yet but Donald Trump has endorsed the
book it's a big fraud two of the ten
chapters in here about January 6th that
is me on the cover as the last member to
leave the household on January 6th and I
know a little bit about January 6th
because uh speaker McCarthy now speaker
McCarthy asked me to be one of the five
to be on that select committee that
Nancy Pelosi rejected so I have a little
information about Jan or six I have a
law enforcement background 30 years I
share for Fort Bend County Texas for
eight and it was a law enforcement
failure so and if you listen to Tucker
the other day about those fourteen
thousand hours that January stuff 40.
well he had he was reviewing thousands
of hours but I'll tell you what it it
Tucker was right on Target and it's
almost like he read my book
I bet he did yes sir he seems like
reader yeah the big frog get on Amazon
want the number one uh under elections
uh there for a while on Amazon so wow
it's doing very very well and and the
Donald he supports it and right on well
we have a lot to talk about as it
pertains to the the going after the
president the fraud so uh thanks for
joining us should be good we also have
Hannah Claire hanging out hi I'm Hannah
Claire brimlow I'm a writer for
timcast.com
and we got Phil about D Ian is off
tonight hello I am Phil Labonte the lead
singer of All That Remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
what's up Serge it's a lot of things
it's a lot of things
I am at surge.com ready to do this let's
go let's jump into that first story we
got this from The Daily Mail exclusive
Trump will not be arraigned this week
former president is expected to be
indicted tomorrow and Secret Service
will make plans for his surrender and
appearance in New York Court next week a
source familiar with the proceedings
exclusively told dailymail.com on
Tuesday there will be no arraignment
this week he's expected to be indicted
Wednesday after which the DA's office
will reach out to his secret service
detail to make arrangements for his
surrender all 36 000 NYPD officers are
in uniform and on notice for deployment
after Trump called for supporters to
protest his imminent indictment now the
question is
will there be a perp walk
if that question is for me I will tell
you that Alvin Bragg he's the Manhattan
D.A going after Trump he doesn't like
Trump it's quite clear he despises the
man he's trying to damage the the former
president I think maybe uh this Mr uh
Alvin Bragg wants to be the governor
maybe one day but he's going after Trump
uh I think it's going to backfire the
perp walk wouldn't surprise me I think
they're going to have to figure out how
that's going to work uh with the Secret
Service I ran a County Jail a big jail
you can't just get Donald Trump and put
him in a holding cell and general
population you ain't going to do any of
that I believe that there will be a
booking photo though I believe that's
going to happen to place the uh the
president United States former president
handcuffs you just don't do it
especially for a a misdemeanor crime
like this which is going through an
indictment I can't figure that one out
but it's it's not a well a violent crime
timing that's right I got a book on it
so no I think he's going to do it it's
all about Donald Trump for 2024 that's
what this is it's about 2024 keeping
them off The Ballot or trying to this
has never happened before a former
president being arrested so so what they
they they book him and as they're
bringing him in the Secret Service is
with him the whole time whole time he's
in the temporary holding cell awaiting
processing and he's got two Secret
Service guys with him then they bring
him to general population at the county
or local jail or it's Manhattan so I
think that's on um what street is that
on I can't remember what street but it's
a lower uh Lower Manhattan so he's going
to be inside there in the cell with a
bunch of other guys and the Secret
Service guards are going to be standing
in front of him in the jail with him
there's just no way there's no
logistical way that that would happen I
mean are they also going to inspect the
Secret Service members and put them in
handcuffs like it doesn't it doesn't
make any sense and then the camera
stopped working and the guards fall
asleep
I imagine the secret service is not
going to surrender their sidearms I
imagine that the president will be
as my I mean he's he's the foreign
president you know the the same protocol
is going to apply for him going to be
booked uh as for anything else I think
that it's pretty clear that this isn't
he's not going to go to jail for this
like I I don't imagine that it's that
this is even a jailable offense it's
like a 500 fine yeah so this is this is
all just and it's and yeah here's the
crazy thing the the charge is basically
bad bookkeeping so here's here's here's
what happens they're saying that the
money he paid to Stormy Daniels was
because uh he was paying her off and
then he listed it as legal fees and
that's a crime so he's going to get
charged or whatever it's like when when
when you're filing your taxes or
whatever you're doing your accounting if
you mislabel something do you know what
happens they call you up on the phone or
they show up and knock on your door or
get a letter typically you get a letter
I don't think they call you at all yeah
you'll get a letter and it'll say we
believe this was an error you owe us X
dollars and then you respond with okay
that that's it yeah well the doj uh they
declined uh to prosecute Trump on this
deal with with stormy so I think they
went after Michael Cohen obviously uh
Trump's attorney back then so Michael
Cohen obviously got three years in
prison related to things with with
Russia collusion stuff so no I I will
say this uh Donald Trump is going to
drive into this sally port he's going to
go into a processing room they probably
are going to fingerprint him but they're
not going to wipe it on his hands it's
all done electronically he'll never
reach a jail cell they'll take a picture
of him and he'll be out the door within
45 minutes it'll be the best thing for
him I think Trump uh if Trump was smart
I'm imagining that right now with his
campaign staff he's saying please
everybody your thoughts and prayers that
they arrest me tomorrow or next week
please please everybody cross your
fingers send your thoughts and prayers
that I do get arrested it's going to be
the biggest thing for for Trump
supporters it's going to pull the it's
going to take the wind out of the sails
of the left yay you did it Trump's been
arrested have a nice day it's done it's
over and for everyone everyone who
supports Trump or even people in the
middle it's going to be hey look they're
trying to arrest their political rival
or they're trying to use the weight of
criminal law enforcement to stop their
principal political rival I don't see
how any how you could characterize it in
any other way it's an obvious
political stunt it's it's an attempt for
the Democratic party the Democrats to go
after Donald Trump yeah all it's going
to do is show middle American voters who
supported Trump that if if Trump can be
arrested then the Democrats can bring
the weight of law against you right it
reminds people how vulnerable they are
especially if they're in counties where
the D.A or you know any part of uh the
judicial system is left and has been
elected I mean it shows you that they
are not willing to draw like if they
aren't willing to draw the line at the
former president what would stop them
from persecuting you yeah there's
nothing I don't think that there's I
don't think that this is is a situation
where Trump is going to be it's not
going to make your average middle of the
road uh voter more sympathetic to Trump
uh it's definitely going to Galvanize
the base it might get some people on the
edges but I don't see how it's going to
change a lot of people's minds it it
it's it's going to have a positive
impact for Donald Trump on Independent
independent voters okay so what there's
an article in Politico and it's like
don't overthink it an arrest for Trump
is bad and I'm just like these people
are so stupid they are the stupidest
people ever in corporate press the
Democratic party they don't know that
there's no such thing as bad press Trump
capitalized on bad press in 2015 and 16
to get elected the media wouldn't shut
about him everything was negative and he
won they seem to think that this
political article said he will not earn
a single new voter and that's the most
that's the stupidest thing possible yeah
he's not going to lose a single voter
and the worst case scenario is he
doesn't get any voters but the likely
scenario is someone will see Trump on
the TV again and be like oh yeah I'm
gonna vote for Trump so I'm on TV don't
even know what happened
I don't think he I don't think he loses
I don't think he loses a single vote
over this no no but he's going to gain
votes yeah this is what people don't get
these these Democrats we we had the
krasensteins on these liberal pundits
and they said they thought the economy
was pretty good or or good and I'm like
that makes sense if you look at the
polling liberals think the economy is
good it's this it's the stupidest thing
I've ever heard by no objective standard
is the economy doing well but they think
it is okay that's the same thing with
Trump being arrested regular people who
don't care all that much are seeing this
and going just stop already man I'm
gonna vote for the guy to spite now
because people won't shut them up
well nobody knew who Alvin Breg was
until this story came out so his name is
probably Ben used and talked about more
in the last 24 hours than anybody in
America I didn't and I'm I'm fairly well
versed on who's who he's going to be the
guy that says I was the one to
accomplish this many many people have
wanted to see Donald Trump in either
handcuffs or arrested because they feel
he's a criminal he's the one able to get
it done he'll be looked at it here with
the far left nut jobs and everybody over
there and uh I I think it's shameful I
think it's abusive office I just saw a
little tweet or something that Rand Paul
put out there said we ought to be
arresting Alvin Bragg for abusing his
office and abusing his power but I think
this helps Donald Trump this is a
two-way race between he and DeSantis and
quite honestly desantis's comments the
other day when he had an opportunity to
speak about it he failed miserably
agreed yeah we talked about it I like
that he called out the Soros D.A and
said they're bad
but then he just said and I get involved
when he should have said you dare not
step one foot on Floridian soil to try
and take Donald Trump he will not be
extradited and we will use Force to stop
you that's what he should have said
and we mentioned the other day Carrie
like would have said it or something to
that effect
I don't see why he didn't say it right
like I know that because he wants to be
president yeah but even then if he
really thinks he has a chance to face
off against Trump that would have
potentially won the hearts of Trump's
base right saying like yeah we're going
to defend Trump like what's happening is
an abusive power would have benefited
him if he was serious about trying to
run stops I don't think anyone really
thinks DeSantis is going to beat Trump
everyone's just so scared and that's
what I I said the other day I'm just so
pissed off everyone is so scared sitting
there cowering worried about what's
going to happen it's like the only
reason the bad things are happening is
because good men do nothing that's it so
DeSantis he gets like a c-minus you know
it was a c minus statement ah yeah he
called out Soros Diaz they're garbage
you know Soros is a bad dude he's
putting in people who are letting
criminals go it's like the villains from
DC comic books but he really didn't make
a strong statement on on defending Trump
Hannah I think that uh uh Donald Trump
is in desantis's head every day he's
living in his head I felt it as comments
are irresponsible number one he never
mentioned Trump once in his what 90
seconds what he did make very clear is
most of the American people probably
have no clue or would have any clue why
Donald Trump was indicted by this
Manhattan D.A
but DeSantis made it very clear what did
he say and I said shame on him for
saying he said you know I don't know you
know how this this porn star stuff and
hush money works that's what he said
yeah and that was a low jab and when
when you think about Ron DeSantis you
know when Trump was kind of attacking
him for the past several months and and
then Santa says I'm going to stay above
The Fray I'm not gonna I got a state to
run I'm not going to get in the name
calling this and that he just violated
what he said he wouldn't he would never
do and shame on him it's he's done he's
done DeSantis is done and he
accidentally I hope accidentally said
I'm happy I'm the only one who removed
osoros D.A and I'm like you're happy
you're the only one shouldn't you be
saying I'm I'm upset I'm the only one
who did it like we should be why am I
the only one yes not being glad you're
the only one who's doing it uh yeah this
was a was a was a big
net negative in my opinion for DeSantis
he had he had a strong opportunity to uh
be to take the lead he didn't take it
I think I think his whether it's the
Paul Ryan's and the others that are
around him given him a bad advice but
listen obviously he's a great Governor
he's done a great job in Florida I think
he has a bright future he's he he has to
run in 2024 because he could lose his
Shine by 2028. so he really doesn't have
much of a choice but he's got one guy in
the way and that's the leader of our
party and that's the holiday Trump he
needs to apologize to Trump call Trump
up and say I'm sorry don't jump in the
race because he hasn't announced yet say
Donald Trump I'd love to be your running
mate let's go out there and save this
great country from the radical left and
DeSantis could be the president 2028. I
wanna I agree uh I we've got a story
about this but I want to hold off for a
little bit because I want to uh just
stand the Trump uh the Trump train for
the moment because we have this tweet
here that I want y'all to see so we can
talk about this is from debate Society
of Berkeley AI is getting out of hand
y'all got me excited for nothing and
there are several photos AI generated of
trump being arrested and they're pretty
good so the first one where showing is
just a bunch of NYPD cops holding Trump
who looks Panic to the next one is Trump
apparently resisting arrest as a bunch
of COPS stand around him and try to lock
him up the next one is that this is
really funny this is my favorite one
Trump running panicked as some cops
aren't even looking at him and are
running apparently the other direction
so okay and then the last one is Trump
once again resisting arrest as cops are
you know yelling and pinning him down
and this cop here he's got he's got a
strange little hand you can't really see
it but uh the reason why I think this is
significant
we talked about it before with the AI
stuff people started making fake posts
and uh and and deep fakes that Trump had
already been indicted that Trump was
being arrested and then they make photos
like this I saw a bunch of these going
around people were like you know Trump
surrenders and some weren't as crazy as
this
but these photos
they're going to be hard to tell if
they're real
at a glance so what happens in 5200
years when some kid is looking through
the archives and he sees photos and he's
like I don't know which one's the real
one
it's dangerous yeah it's very I mean
history is being erased I mean we just
said that it's unlikely that we'll get
this big cuffing moment of trump but
they don't need it if they can just fake
it right if the idea is that the me the
media which is dominating the left wing
in this country wants a picture of trump
in handcuffs all they need to do is you
know run one on the evening news that's
been AI generated and then issue an
apology the next day it's already too
late at that point they've exposed this
fake photo what happens if someone
someone right now who's I say 60 years
old they're not on Twitter they're not
on the internet they have no idea and
they turn on the Tucker Carlson they
turn on the Fox News and they're sitting
there and Tucker is like it's all an
outrage none of this is real and he's
like yeah you tell him Tucker and then
he goes to the bar where he meets up
with his friends and his friends like he
puts his glass on and says let me let me
show you this picture and then he holds
it up for everybody and they see a
photograph of trump being arrested and
they go
no what is this that wow and they
believe it because they don't know
what's going on this my point is there
are probably a lot of people who
genuinely believe Trump was arrested and
these photos may be real
I think it's like the Fulfillment of a
fantasy for a lot of people like they'll
believe the photos even when you can
tell that these are sort of not right
the lighting's not right that one guy's
got a bizarre hand but it's the
Fulfillment of this thing that they've
been rabidly jonesing for for what four
plus years at this point they want Trump
and handcuffs so badly that they are
willing to believe uh a completely fake
photo I I hope they arrest them all
those cops are the same cop if you look
at that picture they're all the same guy
no and that's the cop that one that's
what they look like they really really
look similar and yeah you just racially
profiling New York City right you are
now I see that photo and I'm like that
looks like
every protest I've ever been to yeah but
what I'll say I'm gonna go I I do hope
Trump gets arrested I really really hope
he does I hope I hope they go down to
Florida a bunch of a bunch of cops
around his house they knock on his door
they get a warrant Trump answers and
they say Mr President you're under
arrest I hope it happens so the facade
of our democracy can finally be over
because I tweeted that and you get all
these lefties laughing and being like
dude and I'm like okay listen
when Barack Obama can murder a 16 year
old American citizen without charge or
trial and get nothing nothing not so
much as a bad word could be said about
him by any of you people
then you want to arrest Donald Trump
because he asked he said I'll give you
some money if you claim that we didn't
bang like that's the crime of the
century for which you are going to go
and arrest so I'm kidding about going to
assess and actually arresting him but I
hope the arrest happens I hope he shows
up and they say haha we got him now
because then we can stop pretending like
these people are anything other than
Psychopaths who are trying to steal
power a couple years ago when Steve
Bannon uh turned himself in cfbi because
of whatever charges they're bringing
against him he I mean it was kind of a
it wasn't the most Monumental but I do
remember it being sort of powerful
watching him say like I'm gonna do this
like we've got to keep fighting whatever
else going in and then like obviously
the legal battle continues but it does
have this moment where you feel like
okay we've got to move forward like it
had it had weight behind it in some ways
I feel like Trump you know showing up
wherever being like I'm gonna turn
myself in I'm surrendering custody
because like we cannot keep going this
way and this is uh an abusive power like
it will give him a platform in this very
powerful moment that yes obviously I
wish they wouldn't arrest him but on the
other hand like I don't think they
follow anything logical they're not
bound by the ethics that I think most
Americans are bound by and so we might
as well make the most of this thing like
that's why I was glad that he announced
like yes they're going to arrest me like
I'm telling you right now it's about to
happen like this is what our democracy
has come to it's sort of powerful it's
it's political theater in a way that I
wish we didn't have it on the other hand
I'm glad he's taking advantage of it
yeah I mean I guess it's a good thing
that he's he's going to well I mean it
it seems obvious that if he's going to
be arrested that he should capitalize on
it I mean if they're going to make these
moves he should do uh you know obviously
should do whatever he can he shouldn't
let them set the narrative yeah he
should he should he should definitely do
whatever he can to set the narrative and
having pictures of himself in handcuffs
or having his mug shot as a campaign ad
as the first president that's ever been
arrested by the opposing party when the
opposing party is in power you know like
and the I think that it's powerful I
think that it will matter to
too obviously to Mega people and we'll
get a far get them fired up and that
could make a difference in the polls but
it's still a long way away and we don't
know who else is going to be running and
stuff so I don't know that this matters
in 2024 it'll matter today and for the
next you know the news cycle probably
for a couple maybe a week or two but do
you feel like the left's Turning Trump
into a martyr with this action well
that's exactly what's happening they've
been the left is they've been going
after Trump now for decades it's just
that in the last four or six years about
your collusion oh that's the impeachment
everything they're they're concerned
about Donald Trump and you have to ask
yourself you know if Donald Trump truly
lost the 2020 election why are they
going after him now right well I mean if
he truly lost the election why are they
going after him you would think
7 million volts right 2020 what do you
lose by seven million 71 million
decision it was like 10 or something
okay 11 million or maybe maybe you're
right maybe it was like seven or eight
okay but the point is he lost by several
million he lost the electors by 60 or
70. you would think you'd want the same
guy coming back in four years why don't
they want that man coming back why do
they because they have to paint him as a
as is like a criminal that this guy's
got to be put in jail putting handcuffs
because there's people afraid of them
because people saw Joe Biden
you could only get away with a Joe Biden
one time and they know it do you think
your mind's cut is he the nominee oh
yeah yeah he is what are they going to
do what are they going to get what I I
don't know maybe maybe Michelle wants to
jump in there but I'll tell you
something I'm sending Joe buying 25
bucks
I want Joe Biden to be the nominee so
bad I hope that's who they have they
have a short batch I got it very very
limited I don't think it's a bench it's
like a chair well I want him to be the
number so bad because Donald Trump's
going to be the nominee he'll be the
47th president I agree yeah the when
you had that year a year is an eternity
in politics it doesn't matter what Trump
did in 17 18 and 19. all that matters is
that last year was coven and there was
no Sports there was no movies everybody
was pissed off and they sat in the media
and across the board Trump did it
Joe Biden hid in his basement and people
went out and and you have to look at the
enthusiasm levels enthusiasm for Biden
was was was nil but enthusiasm
enthusiasm against Trump was almost as
high or higher than enthusiasm
enthusiasm for Trump among his base
here's the thing
we now have a Joe Biden the economy is
in shambles we're nearing World War III
all of the things Trump said that were
going to happen have happened or are
happening or about to happen
and regular people are wondering why it
costs six bucks for a dozen eggs
so you can't run the guy again because
all of these problems that have been
going on for years people ain't happy
about yeah do you think they're you
think they're going to run someone else
I'm saying they're going after Trump
desperately because they don't have a
candidate because who are they going to
run Kamala no like there's no obvious
alternative I mean Ojo Biden was
supposed to be the end of the Old Guard
welcoming in this new era and you know
Noah
that's their best I bet they would it's
the only thing they would have Rhonda
Santos if they wanted basically Trump
enough I mean obviously they just give
up and they're alive well the only
person who can beat Trump they like
nominate Joe manchin because he's a
Democrat but like he's the best that
they can do
I mean yeah they were smart that's what
they do but again they set this
precedent of uh we are ending the old
party Democrat right like Pelosi's gone
Joe Biden I think is supposed to be the
last AOC old white president and they
never successfully cultivated a uh
someone to take over for him and he
doesn't want to leave office I mean the
reason Joe Biden hasn't announced is not
because he doesn't want to run it's
because the party doesn't want him to
can you imagine how amazing it would be
if they choose ocasio-cortez
just to see the AOC Trump debates uh
uh it would be just beautiful I'm not
saying anything but I'm saying it'll be
a sight to behold do you mind you have
to do that more people are talking about
Michelle Obama uh today no yeah yeah
yeah and I think Michelle Obama could
she could be one of those she's going to
do it for the good of the country so to
speak she'll be one of those that says I
really don't want to and my husband
doesn't want me to but I have to for the
good of the country you could see her
jump in that that would be a little
scary because I'm concerned about the
electorate and how they vote but we did
get some hope though a couple weeks ago
did we not with with the crime that
we're seeing across the country get rid
of that nut job in Chicago that light
foot oh
just horrible you see the reporters say
get the hell out of this city no no so
maybe people are maybe people in the
cities in these inner cities minority
groups and others are saying you know
what uh our children matter to Crime
matters and inner cities now we've got a
mayor that is just you know the skin the
thing about Chicago is
it was all based on race
so if you look at the election map and
overlay it with the racial neighborhoods
demographics map it's it's the the top
the person who won the neighborhood was
the race of the people who lived in the
neighborhood that was probably the the
in my view the dominant Factor Lori
Lightfoot won
um uh in almost every black neighborhood
and then uh was it Dallas was that the
guy white dude one of the white
neighborhoods and then the Hispanic did
one of the Hispanic neighborhoods and
then in the college areas there was a
woke uh black man who won which is
unsurprising for woke people but it was
almost entirely based on race so I think
what ends up happening is white voters
mobilized due to the crime in their
areas and then voted based on not
necessarily race but principally I I I
should say principally but predominantly
and the reason I say not entirely is
because the woke white people voted for
for a black man but it was shocking to
see the racial breakdowns there yeah I
mean Laura Lightfoot said that she lost
because she's a black woman in America
so she thinks it's about race let me let
me let me because she looks like a bat
yes take a look at this he's been a
rough rough for her this is the most
insane thing
I have ever seen
will see and it will never end
this is a Civics poll showing the
national economy's current condition
right now this polling represents how
Democrats feel about the economy that's
a national election National economy
current condition 49 of democratic
voters believe the economy is fairly
good
fairly good
only 37 think it's bad 26 a fairly bad
11s say very bad seven are unsure and
seven think it's very good
seven percent of Democrats think the
economy is very good okay we'll find
it's low right but
how could anyone think the economy right
now is in any way good these people
they're an occult they are zombies
there's no way you go to the grocery
store and there's no eggs and there's no
milk and you're like everything's great
it's like Nicole I wish that they did
some follow-up questions on like what
markers are you using to say it's fairly
good well take a look at this
Republicans
you've got only four percent of
Republicans saying fairly good less than
a percent say very good 68 say very bad
and they are objectively correct that a
carton of eggs is six bucks in some
places it's four four eighty up to six
bucks that is objectively bad now here's
the best part you look at independent
voters they mostly agree with
Republicans that it's very bad or fairly
bad but about 21 of Independents think
it's fairly good that's because around
21 of Independence probably lean
Democrat but my point with this is
consistently we see the voter base that
Republicans need to win side with
Republicans in their world view and
that's good news the bad news is
Democrats are deranged completely and I
don't know how you save them from
themselves there's a significant portion
of the population that refuse to
acknowledge reality because they hate
the reality that that's going on around
them they don't they don't want Joe
Biden to be a bad president and so so
they're they refuse to acknowledge the
things that Joe Biden has done that were
bad policy and this isn't anything about
Joe Biden as a there none of this is
personal attack this is it would be the
same no matter who the Democrat
candidate is because it's Democrat
policy it's policies that the Democrats
and the left want Joe Biden is a rubber
stamp the man is empty as it gets
because he's he's barely awake when he's
doing things at work uh so this is it's
it's just that the the left does not
want to admit that the policies are not
working you can't have DA's release
criminals after they've been arrested
and expect them to not continue to
commit crime you cannot endlessly print
money and expect there to be no
inflation these things are not in the
control under the control of human
beings like no government has ever been
able to control these types of things
it's ridiculous
you know I'm concerned a little bit
about the electric you know Tammy
mentioned about the independence and we
thought The Independents were going to
do very well for us here in the midterms
here and and you know we only won the
house by what we got a five-seat
majority we thought we were going to do
much much better but I think that's
because of ballot harvesting yeah I
think that the American people I maybe
have short memories I don't know if it's
the ill-in form the uninformed voter
this and that but when when you look at
our our economy today whether it's the
inflation the few prices what's
happening globally with Ukraine and and
all the other stuff China uh and and
crime the southern border under Donald
Trump we didn't have these issues we
have a crisis on every corner in America
today Troy not for nothing but the the
Republicans are the Republicans
responsible it's their responsibility to
get elected the reality is on the ground
have to be brought to the population in
a way that they can understand and see
it that motivates them to get to the
polls to vote and they have Republicans
are responsible for doing that so I mean
it's you're right about everything all
the the it's it's not getting into the
polls it's bringing the polls well fair
enough fair enough this is look
you uh you guys use win red
win red is the online fundraising system
that Republicans use and how how many
years did it take for Republicans to
figure that out Democrats had act blew
up for like I think three years before
Republicans finally figured out how to
take online donations so Democrats are
consistently ahead of Republicans in
figuring how to game the system to win
better they did it with Obama and social
media they did it with win with uh with
uh act blue and then you know
Republicans were late with win red and
now you have ballot harvesting and all
the rule changes that were implemented
and the best Republicans would muster up
was you shouldn't be doing that while
the Democrats did it and then did it
again so they they win through Universal
mail-in voting and ballot harvesting
then 2022 comes around and they double
down and do it more and the best we got
from Republicans both times was oh I'm
wagging my finger at you for doing that
what should have happened is as soon as
2020 was over there should have been an
assessment where they were like how did
here's the problem
so many of trump supporters believed
there's there's no way Biden could get
these votes it's impossible therefore it
must be fraud and I'm sitting here like
or they created Universal mail and
voting they sent the ballots people's
homes everybody was talking about it and
instead of people realizing that if you
knock on someone's door and say hey
that's that thing right there fill that
out I'll take it from you and if you
don't I'll be back tomorrow instead of
believing that's how easy it was they
believed that China was sending in fake
ballots that people were duplicating it
now I'm sure there are probably
instances of people like a mom gets like
three ballots and then she fills them
out for her kids because there was that
lady on the was it on The View she
claimed to have done that she's like I
voted for my son and it was like like
nobody cared and she's not gonna go to
jail or anything like that but the
reality was
you it's easy to mobilize activists in
cities
you go to one building in Manhattan and
you can knock on enough doors to talk to
one thousand people by the end of the
day but a rural area you cannot do that
and so not only Republicans not focused
on ballot collection harvesting and
chasing but they didn't even realize
that before this ground game in cities
is easier so moving into 2024 I think
that's why I think Trump said this we're
going to become about harvesting
Powerhouse and all Republicans are now
realizing like oh wait maybe that's why
we lost the example is Orange County
California traditionally Republican one
day all of a sudden votes Democrat and
everyone's like what how did that happen
the Republican party down there says hey
they're doing ballot harvesting the next
election the Republicans won so I think
the the mood of the nation is correct
regular people independent voters
conservatives Libertarians the freedom
faction we're going to call it people
who aren't in the cult know it's bad and
are pissed off and they would prefer
Donald Trump or at least not a Biden
but with ballot harvesting you got
people who are in their apartment
sitting there playing video games not
comes on their door and they're like
look man I don't know anything about
that politics stuff and they'll go well
why don't you fill out that fill that
out right there it's like all right what
do I just sign it there you go man have
a good day that works so if Republicans
get on that it's going to go back to
normal it's infuriating that that's
that's legal but if that's what we have
to do that's that's a chance to do 26
States I think it's legal yeah some
states have specific restrictions on how
you do it unbelievable but I think
there's like 13 states where you can
just knock on doors and take belts and
and people who are like shocked to find
that in some swing States you can go to
a nursing home with a ballot for every
person or go to the nursing home ask the
nursing home staff to collect all the
mail-in ballots that were delivered
there then have all the elderly people
come into the room and say I'm gonna I'm
gonna deliver your votes for you so why
don't you all fill it out and sign put
my name on it I'll sign it and then I'm
allowed to drop your votes off for you
and all these old people go thank you
for visiting
people don't get it it's that easy so
Republicans got to get on that game and
then they'll win so do you think
Republicans are ready for that going
into 2024 I mean have a republican Scott
Pressler is out there working his
fingers to the Bone and they disrespect
this guy they need to put him in charge
of like the rnc's Outreach or whatever
get him on on this program he'll take
care of it for all of you guys is that
what the issue was with Carrie Lake I
don't know if that was the issue of
Carrie like I think Carrie Lake was
saying that a lot of these polling
locations that that were mostly uh in
areas where it was strongly Conservative
Republican you know had issues either
with the with the voting machines or
they were running out of paper they had
issues with the ballot so I think it's a
multi-faceted it's it's all sorts of
issues the Democrats have been better at
it I think the Democrats have become
very good at cheating and what's that's
what they do they cheat I'm not saying
that we got to get better at cheating
but we have to get some Integrity back
into our electoral process our process
of of Elections and I I think it would
be very simple we should just have one
day there's no reason we need to have
two three weeks I agree we should have
one day of voting you know and as
Afghanistan you put the little uh you
put the little ink on the finger and you
put it on the ballot you know it stayed
there for three days we know if you
voted before you know you can't bring a
different finger back and I just think
we've got to cut down to one day and and
hit paper ballots get rid of the
machines paper ballots one day making a
national holiday agreed France can do it
these other countries do it was it like
France they have like a glass box and
you walk up and put it in there's people
watching from different parties and they
watch it all happen it's that simple
yeah but I agree with you the Democrats
are very very good at cheating and
Republicans suck at it but let's define
what cheating is they go to the state
legislatures and they change the rules
to favor themselves they Implement
Universal mail-in voting to favor
themselves all of these things were done
through a legal process now in many
instances these processes were
challenged and their allies in the court
said no everything's fine uh
Pennsylvania being the best example
Texas sued Pennsylvania I think 48
states were involved it was insane and a
lower Court ruled that actually
Universal mail and voting was
unconstitutional and the Republicans
would likely win on the merits but the
Supreme Court of Pennsylvania is mostly
Democrat and they said actually no
despite the fact the Constitution
doesn't allow this we are going to so
you can call it cheating or you can call
it something like procedural
manipulation I think it was it was
really done uh what cost Donald Trump
the election 2020 was covered it was
coveted it was the uh the the emergency
declaration Governor Evers up in the
state of Wisconsin a good example he
created the safer at home policy where
everybody pretty much just got a ballot
ever Universal ballot pretty much 1.3
million ballots would be returned in the
state of Wisconsin 1.3 million and and
they didn't even they didn't reject 3
000 of them I think 2 900 and change
there was so much fraud in the state of
Wisconsin and he did it under this under
the the the executive order that was
there at the national level so he made a
decision on his own and they bypassed
the state laws the state legislatures
and the election laws because you had
this emergency declaration but but look
this is the issue this is why I think
Republicans it's not fraud
they're they're manipulating the system
they're gaming the system they had a
process by which they implement this
procedure through the system in
Pennsylvania the Republicans agreed with
Democrats on universal mail and voting
and this is what the lawsuit was partly
about that in order to implement
Universal mail-in voting you have to
have an amendment to the Constitution
which requires printing at newspapers
and getting a vote putting it on the
ballot in November and then waiting till
afterwards and establish Republicans and
Democrats worked together through the
traditional legislative process and
passed a law allowing them to do it the
problem then is a lot of people come out
and they scream fraud and it's like this
is what they're doing is they're
dangling keys to your left and then
smacking you with their right hand if
you if you approach this from the
perspective that there's some kind of
illegal activity or malfeasance you've
lost because they won in the courts they
have their allies in the courts
defending them as they use the process
to win it's just like what I was saying
with act blue and win red Democrats
launched an online donation system BLM I
think went through act blue which
allowed some of the donations for BLM I
could be wrong it's been a while to
cover this to funnel into the Democrats
fundraising apparatus which was
effectively empowering the Democratic
party through donations to political
activist groups which technically you
could argue is fraud but it's not it's
completely legal
so as long as Republicans don't realize
they will they will Slither their way
through every crack in the legal system
in ways that we would be like hey that's
not fair you're cheating they go
according to all of these statutes we
did it by the book and they did so
that's why Donald Trump comes out and
says we need to ballot Harvest it's it's
you're you're right there has to be
ballot harvesting but the the RNC has to
be better than the DNC right like the
RNC the ground game of the Republicans
has to be and I'm not talking about the
politicians the people that are running
I'm talking about the people that are
administrating elections that are
working on policy that are that are on
in the states at the state level they
have to be on top of it because all the
the reasons that Donald Trump got
elected or didn't get elected and didn't
win the the election is because of the
procedural stuff that the Democrats
managed to do in several states he
should have won it I think that the the
the issues with them not getting you
know with the covet and stuff had had a
significant part of it but the the at
the end of the day
the responsibility for winning the
election goes to the Republican party
and to the candidate and no matter what
the Democrats do if the Republicans
aren't ready for it in my opinion like
the and the Democrats win that's the
failure of the Republican party and
that's detrimental to the United States
as a country I think there was enough uh
for me to make a decision obviously I
objected to Arizona Pennsylvania that
you talk about with Pennsylvania Tim and
there are certain amount of there were
many of us that objected to the electors
in this debt because I do believe Donald
Trump was cheated out of this election
and uh and and I will go to my grave
with that we have to get a hold we have
to get a grip on this because the
American people if we lose our our
elections and the American people feel
that their vote could be manipulated or
lost or not counted or whatever it may
be I mean that's a sad State of Affairs
we lose our country we better get a grip
on this thing uh we got to find a way to
streamline the process yes it's up to
the individual States I don't want I
don't want a federal takeover of our
elections don't get me wrong but some of
these states need to to get together and
and uh and look at their their election
laws and make sure that they're fair for
everybody there's you know the idea to
say we shouldn't you don't need an ID I
mean that's how that's how silly it gets
though as it relates to uh you know not
allowing uh people of color and and
minorities you you should need an ID I
mean we are so wide so far apart on this
uh with Republicans and Democrats and
because we don't want to have voter
suppression Tim God forbid so the the
state's legislatures got they got to get
to work the the the the view I suppose
is
if here here's a way I'll phrase it if
we had one day of voting as the
Constitution prescribes
with ma with ID requirements like you
have to prove you you you are in the
right place to vote
Donald Trump would easily be the
president
and so when people on the right say he
was cheated it gets lost on a lot of
middle of the road people who have heard
too much from Trump about fraud and
theft and stolen and with the corporate
press's depiction in the worst possible
way of what it is people on the right
are talking about it's hard to
understand that's why my view is my the
way I phrase it is consistently
Democrats used procedural smarmy tactics
to win they do things like a month of
voting they do things like Universal
male and mail-in voting it's all done
above board but it's
nefarious it's malicious and I guess
what I mean is they're they're betting
on their voters being so ignorant to the
process that they can Implement things
that are destroying the system
but it's done through through the rules
right there was a I can't remember the
guy's name he said the United States has
a loophole that can destroy it can be
destroyed very easily and that is the
amendment process the fact that you can
amend the Constitution to destroy itself
is a loophole for the destruction of
this country that's what Democrats do
they use the legal process in the
prescribed legal manner to exploit and
win and steal power
that's what I see them as doing like
they didn't they didn't just send it
they didn't just one day wake up and
start sending out mail-in votes
illegally they went to the governors
they went to the legislature of their
states and they said we want to do this
and then they said okay and then they
did it so
a legal process only requires the
consent of the people who are signing
off on the legislation and then the the
executive of the state to rubber stamp
it and send it through
and there you go what did they do wrong
and in some of those States uh obviously
there's a difference between Universal
ballot and ballot by mail you get a
ballot by mail you know you have to
qualify you could be either serving in
the military or overseas or you could be
out of state or whatever the case would
be over 65 disabled this that but in the
state of Wisconsin he pretty much took
covet under the color covet and made it
in Wisconsin Universal ballot that's
what they did in Wisconsin and that's
how they got 1.3 million votes and they
they did it and many of them many of
them to think about 1.3 million votes
coming out of Dane County coming out of
Milwaukee uh the two most liberal areas
in Wisconsin and Trump loses by Twenty
Thousand they rejected less than three
thousand of 1.3 million
signature verification though but you
know that that some of these envelopes
were missing from the battle but that's
that's that's that's it look so that's
what the fraud in my opinion comes in
there was some fraud was there enough
fraud no but it's but change it but but
are we talking about a crime are we
talking about you are mad that you lost
well I just well number one I never said
Trump ever lost no no what I'm saying
won the election these these these
Democrats beat the Republican party they
beat Donald Trump they won and they won
through the process because I have
watched this happen my whole life like
that's why I use the winrad ACT blue uh
example it is the perfect example I when
I first heard that because I had a
friend who had worked on some Republican
or initially was working for Democrats
and then switched governments are
working for republicans and she told me
the Republicans didn't start online
fundraising until like three or four
years after Democrats did I'm like that
is it but if you if if what's
frustrating to me is
we know it's ballot harvesting because
we saw it in Orange County it
exemplified it we know that mail-in
votes are overwhelmingly Democrat we
know that they champion this because
they go to nursing homes and it's legal
to do this well of course they're not
going to reject their own ballots you
can argue that they're supposed to but
that's not even fraud that's just bad
procedure I guess that the people who
are supposed to running elections aren't
rejecting ballots what do you say about
that how do you prove they were or
weren't supposed to the worst case
scenario is if you were to actually
review those ballots you'd say you made
a mistake these should be uh how do you
prove intent how do you prove anything
other than they're going to do things
that benefit themselves through the
process in the legal system and they do
it all the time and then I'm watching
this happen I'm watching people like
Scott Pressler go to Florida for
instance and flip so many people and
register so many Republicans turning the
state red and then Rhonda Santos wins by
a million votes and I'm like look at
this stuff they're doing that's working
and then I just hear from Trump and I
hear from a bunch of trump supporters
that like oh well it was fraud and they
cheated and I'm like well that's an
effective way to lose we need to address
exactly what they did and how they did
it they are sitting inside the chambers
of their state legislatures smiling and
smoking cigars as they rubber stamp
policies that guarantee them victories
and then I just keep hearing from
everybody now they cheated this is what
okay dude this is why I'm so I was so
surprised that Harmony Dylan or didn't
win the the chair of the the RNC I feel
like the Republicans need to have needed
to have some kind of change of
leadership because they completely
dropped the ball they blew it really bad
with the the the fact that Joe Biden got
elected and then I think that the the
Army Dillons the the election for the
the chair of the RNC was after uh the
election in November wasn't it so so
they blew it in the midterms too yeah
she gets to keep her job this is the
epitome of failing up
look like this is why I tweeted a couple
days ago we must actively destroy the
Democrat and Republican parties the
Republican party has a large percentage
of good people I think you do a great
job obviously Matt Gates is fantastic
Lauren bobert does a good job market
Taylor Graham the whole Freedom caucus
is pretty yeah absolutely and then and a
few others too and the Democrats have
like one guy who's like maybe okay like
rokana we're kind of like well I might
be okay requires a good guy yeah Henry's
a good guy what do you like about him I
just like he's pro-life and he's
reasonable all right well that's that's
reasonable
I see a malicious and evil Democratic
Leadership and I see an incompetent and
placative Republican party or whatever
they they either uh
this is I mean look the the the RNC
Harmony don't think is a perfect example
how did that happen I mean the
Republicans don't deserve my vote I
would I would so I would be so it would
be so preferable for me to vote for Dave
Smith the libertarian party but I don't
want Democrats to win and I do like
Donald Trump but man do I really despise
the Republican leadership I've never
been a republican never been a fan of
Republicans I think like like I
mentioned the win red act blue thing as
an example of incompetence to me is just
so profound and when you get an
opportunity with harmeet Dylan to
actually do something they reject it oh
it would feel so good if they would all
lose again because I'm because it's it's
like how many times you gotta flog
yourself until you correct your bad
behaviors I suppose the real issue is
that the Republican leadership is
purposely trying to help the Democratic
establishment win because they're all
part of the same uni party and that it's
only the freedom caucus and other
Republican upstarts that are actually
trying to do something so we're all
spinning our wheels and Donald Trump was
an accident that pissed off the
Republican leadership I mean didn't
Kevin McCarthy say Trump worked for
Putin oh now he changes his tune because
he's getting forced to do do so I still
don't like these people I just see so
much excuse making and a refusal to
actually make the changes that need to
be made to fix the problem I'm not sure
it can be fixed you know I it's easy for
me to sit here and complain you're
actually there doing the work I'm just
some dude complaining on the internet so
what do I know how how much are you in
contact with like the RNC and do you
feel like they understand that that you
know about harvesting is the future if
they want to win do you feel like there
are people at the RNC that actually are
are on these problems and and and are
going to address the issues or do you
think they're just going to be like well
you know you got a job yeah I really
don't have conversations with Rhonda
McDaniel she was reelected I I will say
this there's about 25 to 30 of us or 35
to 40 of us in the in the freedom caucus
it's a it's a great organization it's a
great group of people very smart people
you mentioned some very smart people in
that group and we consider ourselves
America First Patriots we put America
First many of us obviously have never
voted for it that's even increase we've
got some of that coming up many of us
don't necessarily support all the
funding going to Ukraine many of us want
to see a secure Southern border many of
us want to see election integrity and
and many of us understand that this
government's gotten way too big it's out
of control the spending's out of control
many of you we come up well in the
freedom caucus in the freedom caucus I I
can't we need more members uh that that
are like us the fiscal conservatives the
ones that truly understand what 31
trillion dollars really means uh and and
and so it's trying to find people that
are willing to take the fight to
Washington Donald Trump did that and
that's why the establishment despised
him and that's why you have guys like
Paul Ryan and some of these other
individuals saying if Donald Trump is
the nominee if a republican nominee they
won't vote for him in November we ought
to throw individuals like that out of
the Republican party yes listen I'm not
a big fan of DeSantis I think Donald
Trump's the leader of our party but if
DeSantis for some reason becomes the
nominee I'm all in for him in November
I'll take a republican over any Democrat
but you've got some of these rhinos and
some of the establishment that don't
like Donald Trump and they'll just say
the hell with the Republican party and
won't support the nominee that's what's
dangerous we got to kick him out of the
party yes like Liz Cheney Adam kensinger
should have kicked him out they gotta go
weren't they kicked out well we never we
didn't really ever we should have
actually a ceremonial vote but Mike CERN
I think it was Mike cernovich had this
great tweet that um maybe I can actually
try and pull up because I may have
retweeted it and uh it's it's easy
smart dude he's also was like super nice
to me like we don't have any kind of uh
history or anything he was super polite
and cool so let me see if I
yep here we go I got it let me pull it
in
all right he said
uh uh responding to one tweet from Daily
Sunshine Mike's uh Daily Sunshine says
can someone explain how this works why
doesn't more crime result in people
voting out these those responsible for
safety how do these people stay in power
in democracy I see that it works but I
don't understand from a logical
standpoint how it works
Mike cernovich says Democrats do not
have Noble DNA it's the real divide
right-wing people want freedom and
dignity which is why when we have
political power we don't use it
utterfali the left will live as bug men
stacked on each other pooping everywhere
needle needles in their arms
and he's right
so the the the issue is and I think a
really good example is the the RNC chair
after losing and losing and losing and
just being so absurdly bad at running
the show they just re-elect the same
people
over and over again it's it's the
definition of insanity
so I suppose the issue is it's twofold
what Mike is saying is that Republicans
don't use the power
not then you're gonna lose that's it
and the bug men are gonna win
I feel like young conservatives that I
talk to nowadays are more in line with
values that the freedom caucus is
talking about and I think that you're
going to see them become more and more
isolated from the Republican leadership
if they continue on the path they're on
right if the leadership of the party
continues to say no this is the way
we've always done it and we're going to
continue to do it this way they will
lose they will see youth voters pull
away from them and I think as we know if
you can't capture young voters that you
don't really have a future I think in
some ways time is ticking on the Old
Guard in the Republican Party the same
way it's ticking for the Old Guard and
the Democratic party I mean they are
drifting in all kinds of crazy
directions that they cannot keep up with
I
I think DeSantis is a perfect example
I'm I'm really really off uh uh the
DeSantis train I mean I was I was I was
a big understand this a year ago and
following that's the press conference he
gave just seeing how he's been handling
everything that's going on the Press I
am moving further and further away from
him because more and more he represents
to me what the what the failures of the
Republican Party are
he should have got up in front when he
was talking about you know digital
currency Central Bank digital currencies
and he's doing a lot of good things by
being up to date with the problems we're
facing with the culture war with
economic issues I respect that that's a
good thing
and when given the opportunity to be a
leader he said no because he was scared
I think Ron DeSantis was scared he was
scared to say f you to the anti-trump
group for whatever reason if he thinks
he is going to win
any voter from Trump by being weaker
than Trump he is completely wrong and
I'm just I'm looking at what Mike
cernovich said and he made a great point
that Republicans or he said the right
want freedom but anyway they won't use
power he's completely right
just a bunch of cowards and I I I it's
just every step of the way
the the Democrats let's talk about ilhan
Omar and and Marjorie Taylor green
Marjorie Taylor green gets booted off
our committees because a couple of years
before she's elected she posts some
rambling incoherent thing about space
lasers funded by a Rothschild's Bank the
media then spins that into anti-Semitism
and then she's booted from her
committees because Republicans are
cowards not all of them Freedom caucus
you guys are pretty good but then you
get ilhan Omar who makes these repeated
statements in office and then they're
like well you know but let's not uh go
be too hasty there let's just condemn
all bigotry and that's what ends up
happening because the Democrats antifa
these these leftists they can steamroll
they can fire bomb and the media
protects them and Republicans are like
well you know I would say something but
the New York Times will write a mean hit
piece about me so I'm like oh well
that's why people wanted Trump because
Trump told the media to f off and so
they're like there you go you do that do
more of that that's why I was really
excited for pushing back on Kevin
McCarthy when that whole fight happened
we did they were yeah uh as it relates
to Omar she was removed she was voted
off of her a foreign affairs committee
she was after how many years Eric
swalwell he was removed off of uh Intel
because of his relationship with yum yum
[Laughter]
so yeah yum yum so so he's gone but but
we have made it very clear and and uh
listen I was one of the ones I was one
of the freedom caucus guys that gave one
of the uh the nomination speeches for
Kevin McCarthy because I thought that
the battle the real battle uh in the
Republican party is going to be uh when
this important legislation comes through
like the debt ceiling I mean it's been
pretty easy peasy up to this point but
we got these debt sealing increases and
and and trying to actually pass a budget
and we do spending that's when it's
going to start getting very very
difficult for speaker McCarthy and and I
just believe that that right now every
decision that we make as the majority
Authority in the House of
Representatives has to be in the best
interest of getting the White House back
in 2024 because we're talking about
listen we got a great plan Texas uh we
we all came together the representatives
a good border security plan even if we
could get that out of the house it's
dead in the Senate I mean I don't want
to be the bearer of bad news but we
could come up with all the greatest
ideas in the world here in the next two
years with the Republican majority in
the House of Representatives but going
to the Senate and getting anything done
I I can't tell you so that's why it's
right now it's all about investigations
because we've got to expose these
individuals the crooks for who they are
so we can get the White House back in
2024. but legislatively you're just kind
of running out the clock well there's
nothing Well no I think we owe it to the
American people they gave us the gavel
they're begging for leadership so they
gave us the House of Representatives so
now let's lead let's do everything we
can to pass meaningful conservative
legislation through the house let the
American people know that we actually
really care about leadership and and
doing the right thing for America and
America first but then it's going to go
to the Senate run by the Democrats and
it's dead so I think now it's all about
investigations because we need to expose
this family the most corrupt family and
in my humble opinion never served in the
white house we got to expose them for
who they truly are and all of his
friends in the doj the FBI all of them I
don't be doing investigations just
because you you actually cannot pass any
legislation because of the Senate you
should just go and investigate because
you've got nothing better to do but I
don't think that's going to win
anything in 2024. because the game is
different right now likely voters don't
don't matter the reason why the polling
didn't make sense right the polls in the
midterm showed it was going to be
tremendous for the Republican party and
then it was meh and the reason for it is
because when pollsters contact likely
voters and say how do you plan on voting
the likely voter tells them they make a
poll based on it the likely voter then
said Republicans all the way
then they went and knocked on doors at
nursing homes and apartments and got
random non-voters to vote this changed
everything and that's probably the main
reason it was so skewed this time and
Republicans were caught off guard that's
the game right now you don't need this
is this is what the Republicans the
Republican mindset
is I'm gonna go convince that person to
vote for me and the Democrats mindset is
I'm Gonna Knock on their door and tell
them to sign a piece of paper
and that's why they win
they don't got to convince them of
anything
they can they can use social pressure
and fear
or they can make they can remove all
barriers so you got someone knock on
your door and they say what do you want
I'm in the middle of the game did you
fill out your mail-in vote and vote for
the Democrat no I don't want to do well
if you don't vote it if you don't fill
it out right now I will be back here
tomorrow at the same time and if if you
don't do it I'll come back and then
every day they knock on the door and the
guy's like you again fine I'll fill the
thing here you go man have a nice day
they win
that's that that's all that matters
going into I'm imagining these like
these large
um Urban uh living complexes project
housing and other developments in New
York for instance how easy it is for two
20 year old Democrat activists
campaigning on behalf of Joe Biden or
anybody else to go into one building in
one day knock on a door did you vote no
fill it out sign sign your sign your
name I can take it for you they turn
around without moving a single inch and
knock on a door behind them and get
another vote here's the crazier thing
each of these doors could have two or
three people behind them
within the matter within a matter of an
hour they can have 50 votes in their in
their bag Republicans can't do that
because conservatives live in rural
areas you're gonna go drive door to door
our closest neighbor to us to take you
about five minutes to walk to or or get
in your car what's Republican oh sorry I
haven't done the research on universal
ballot how many states just mail you a
ballot I don't think it's that many I
think there are some it's the important
one so while it is the important one I
understand that and I haven't looked at
the swing States but I think again it
goes back to the the covet with the
emergency declaration it allowed
Governors Secretary of States and and
even County clerks to start forming
their own opinion uh what the emergency
declaration really meant and how they
could keep their people safe uh social
distancing six feet let's just mail
people a ballot you have to request a
ballot by mail so if if somebody if
you're not gone they're doing
everybody's got a mallet a ballot in
their in their uh I didn't I I
understand but what now in a nursing
home I could understand that because if
you're 65 it's almost automatic if
you've ever requested one you're going
to get another one is that you shouldn't
have to go and reapply every time but
the the fact of the matter is is that is
that's where I believe Tim I believe
that that that there was the fraud
because a lot of these these ballots uh
there's documentation out there that
said I never voted uh but yeah I know
you did vote no I never I never but how
many stories are you talking about well
I I'm not I'm just saying where there's
one there's two there's three the point
is that the process the process that we
have Tim we have to get control of
because it's not fair it's been abused
you could say whether Democrats are
better at it well maybe they truly are
but there's still many many Americans
and many of them on January 6 that came
up to to protest this thing many of us
are concerned about the way this country
runs elections and and we have to do
something about it because we lose the
Integrity of our elections and I agree
with that but if you believe that the
Democrats one in that way you will lose
again in 2024. you barely won in 2022
and you will be crushed in 2024 because
it's it's it's it's you've got I think
establishment Republican types who are
happy to see the Democrats win because
they hate Donald Trump people like you
mentioned Paul Ryan and then you have
the other group that just says we can't
win because they cheated and I'm like
okay well then please lose because I'm
sick of hearing it I got to be honest
like we we I I I remember covering all
of this stuff when Texas was suing
Pennsylvania and they very carefully
laid out the procedures by which they
were able to boost the numbers for
Democrats and I just keep hearing over
and over again a month later that it was
Dominion that it was China that there
were that there were secret ballots were
stuffed under tables and I'm like what
are you talking about they they they
went door to door in Philadelphia
predominantly Democrat City and they
collected these from people because they
use emergency powers to make it legal
like if we're not going to address that
and they've maintained those rules and
and and the Republicans did nothing to
stop them from codifying the emergency
Powers into law
okay
then we lose am I right Tim the state
legislature in Pennsylvania is run by
democrats uh-huh yeah so that way
actually at the time can we look that up
the the universal mail-in voting was was
a deal between Republicans and Democrats
okay the Republicans wanted to get rid
of down ballot you know voting where you
can check off Democrat and vote all
Democrat they thought it would help them
that's the story at least and so they
said okay if we get rid of that we'll
give you Universal mail-in voting
because they're stupid or because they
were in on it and they hate Donald Trump
I wouldn't be surprised to find out that
80 percent of the Republican party is
actively trying to stop Donald Trump as
well especially in the state levels
because you look at Donald Trump getting
elected in first of all 2016 they hated
them they were mad most Republicans were
ragging on saying this is the death of
our party you had prominent conservative
speakers saying the same thing Trump
gets elected and then what for the next
couple of years even the Republican
party was helping the collusion
narrative which turned out to be
complete and utter garbage nonsense how
was that even entertained by a single
Republican you know me I'll I'll take
full blame for being naive and be like
wow I don't know a lot about this what's
this they're saying now about Trump and
this Alpha Bank stuff now it's like
lesson learned how did the Republican
Party fall for that in March in lockstep
helping Democrats do all of this stuff
how did they sit there and help the
impeachment there I don't I just don't
understand it's it's it's it's crazy to
me but I can only assume it's
intentional and then my the the big
problem I have with this this uh
look after the after Trump loses the
election the immediate claim is the most
insane thing I've ever heard servers
being stolen in Germany satellites being
shot down and when I said that's crazy I
had people ragging on me saying I was
Shilling for Biden or whatever and then
I needed to accept what the reality was
people were saying Donald Trump was
going to be reinstated on March 3rd and
I said this is the craziest thing about
this is not going to happen they were
ballot harvesting there's a major
lawsuit about it all of a sudden as time
goes on and Trump doesn't get reinstated
and it's not March then April not April
then may and none of it happens now I'm
saying things like they were ballot
harvesting and these same people are
going finally seeing it our way a Tim
and I'm like this is insane it's it's my
it's just mind-boggling to me but fine
if this is people finally recognizing
that some dude walks into an office so
stamps a piece of paper saying give
everyone a belt whether they want it or
not and then puts it in a box and then I
remember I when I was in New Jersey we
got ballot sent to us without asking for
them
so they're they're they're they're
they're they're doing everything in
their power to make sure battles are
sent to everybody and then it's very
very simple
mom is is collecting the mail and she
walks into the kitchen and there's her
18 and 19 year old kids and she says
fill out your ballots and they go I
don't care about that stuff I'm just
felt your ballots and we're gonna go eat
and they go fine whatever now you got
two votes from two young people who
normally don't vote boom more votes for
Democrats it's it's she fills it out for
them perhaps like that woman from The
View claimed she did but that's
immaterial if the ballots are placed
it's better sign the ballot you've got
to sign the ballot that's who I think
the fraud is now you know I I think
there's no reason to say that there's
absolutely no reason I said other than
to demoralize your voting base well I
just think the the the signature
verification is very well documented
across some of these states but the the
fact of the matter is is that is that we
we had a very difficult time in 2020 I I
believe that uh end of 2022. and and in
2022 and and we got to put a stop to it
2024 it can't be this way we have to do
something maybe it's getting the White
House back in both Champions and doing
something you're not going to get the
White House back with the way things are
going well I mean unless Republicans
start playing the game and figuring out
what Democrats did to win and do the
same thing Republicans will lose again
so what would you like what do you think
though
Donald Trump said it himself ballot
harvesting massive ground game that's
why I said that only works in states
that mail out the swing States like
Pennsylvania but then what else like it
seems like there has to be more than
just one thing because you're saying
that like ground game Republicans are
always behind the Democrats like is
there anything new we should be doing
yes get rid of Ronald McDaniel bring
Harmony delinon have an RNC have an
emergency session right now where they
go hey that election whoopsie gone bring
in harm meat or or anyone else and then
um put Scott Pressler in charge of the
entire National voter Outreach division
he should be in charge he's probably
done more for the Republican party than
any anyone since Abra okay I don't want
to go too hyperbolic here but the dude
went state by state getting people to
register for the Republican Party the
point where in Florida for the first
time ever there were more Republicans
than Democrats the Republicans have
always been miserable at registering new
voters that's why even nationally
there's more Democrats than Republicans
and the Republicans only win when they
can when they finally get independent
voters to swing in their Direction a
little bit Scott Pressler changed that
but for the life of me it seems like
there is a complete inability to
actually say hey let's ask them what
they did
and then do that they wrote a whole
article in Time Magazine the shadow
campaign to save the election explaining
how they changed laws how they
implemented these rules how they did
these programs and then what does the
Republican Party say I don't know it's
probably people committing fraud and
it's like but they wrote a whole thing
breaking down exactly how they did it
they they told you what they did I don't
know it's probably fraud and then okay
and they would never lose then it's like
conservatives just listen to the
argument and just accept it and just say
okay fine or if they've got excuses so
it's all right if the argument is you
want to use the semantic word fraud to
represent that Democrats play
underhanded games I've heard people say
the election was rigged and they're not
saying that like
that someone stole a voting machine and
hacked into it they're saying all right
that the rules were changed in a way to
benefit Democrats I'm like yeah they
wrote a whole article we've talked about
a million times the shadow campaign to
save the election from Time Magazine
where they said powerful Elites Tech
investors you know Financial assets were
used to change rules and get more votes
for Democrats and it worked and it's
like okay
you need to understand that machine they
built how it operates and how to make it
yourself
or it will be 2020 all over again the
fact that 2022 happened and people are
thinking like man I guess we just didn't
do as well as we thought it's like no
they they're maintaining the universal
mail-in voting rules to keep like you
look at Lauren bobert's District right
that was what was that guy's name who
ran against her can't say but he got
close
542 votes I think it was now how is that
possible in a rural gun toting District
it's because even though people live
very far from each other they've got
better ground game what I mean by that
activists who are fervent and cult-like
who will get in their cars and spend
their own time and money to go ballot
chasing and conservative Republicans
don't do that they're just like sitting
at home saying look look what happened
after 2020 with Georgia right you had a
an interview a man on the street thing I
think CNN ran this where he was asked
are you going to vote in the special uh
uh in the runoff and he goes no what's
the point it's rigged anyway and I'm
like you do 2 new things by claiming
that the election was stolen you
demoralize your voter so they don't want
to vote and you don't actually assess
the the methods that Democrats use to
win so I'm like it's frustrating now
going on you know two years or so
hearing people say especially especially
after the midterms when Republicans got
clobbered the Republicans won the house
very narrowly despite the fact that the
national mood is in favor of them
I mean that's a scary Prospect it to me
it feels like Civil War is an
inevitability because the the elections
do not represent what the actual
political mindset of the country is
because Democrats are exploiting
unlikely voters for votes and
Republicans are ignoring it half of them
are screaming that it was that the only
thing they do is cheat not understand
what's actually being done and the other
ever probably sitting back being like
well as long as I'm getting paid I don't
care what happens so but like I you know
Phil brought it up with with Harmony
Dylan I'm like right there
I'm I'm kind of you know I don't know I
want Trump to win I really do DeSantis
is a letdown uh Carey Lake I think
should have won I'd she'd be a great VP
but I'm kind of at the point where it's
just like until the Republican party is
completely destroyed I don't know if I'm
interested anymore as a party I mean the
freedom caucus is great but maybe what
needs to happen is 2024 needs to be so
apocalyptically bad for Republicans that
there's just no interest in being being
Republican anymore and then then finally
we can get rid of people like Ronald
McDaniel then finally there will be no
powerful Intuit like if the Republicans
lose again
then people might actually be like why
should I invest any money in Republicans
they're going to lose
then you will get some prominent
interest in you know the the powers that
be that have failed will leave and then
the door will be open for someone like
armit to finally get in and Scott
Pressler and others to start cleaning
things up hey another great story is
like Robbie Starbuck who was trying to
run for office in I think it was in
Nashville right and the in the
Republican Party blocked him and we're
trying to stop him I'm like
I I'm at the point where I I might just
be satisfied watching the Republicans
lose across the board because there
needs to be a clean a clean house so
that they can finally realize why
they're losing but what makes you think
that when I look at the electorate and I
look at Donald Trump I look at the
policies he had and the results of his
policies over four years
and for many people that I still talk to
that are anti-trump
they can't come up with a policy that
they didn't like
that you know tax cuts and job act I
mean all the stuff wanting to secure the
southern border trying to end endless
Wars all of his policies and all the
great he did for four years there are
still people today that will not vote
for him because they find him to be rude
or obnoxious or a narcissist so are we
really set are the American people truly
concerned about the problems we have are
facing in this country or are we more
concerned about the name calling and and
I've said to my friends I said did he
call you that name the did it affect you
no but you know what Donald Trump's
policies did it affected You by having
inflation at a point and a half and fuel
that was three dollars and all these
positive things that Donald Trump did
but we're more concerned and set I can't
vote for that guy because he's he's just
arrogant and I'm thinking how do you fix
a country when you have people like that
the problem is now it doesn't that vote
doesn't matter if you go and knock on a
guy's door and he's sitting in his
garage watching a football game in his
man cave and he's like I don't know
nothing about that Donald Trump it's
like well you don't like buying do you I
guess he's bad felt this form you got it
buddy have a nice day so that person
says I don't like Trump I won't vote for
him doesn't matter that's like you
that's true but the thing is like I get
what you're saying
but the I I still revert back to my
earlier statement that it's the
responsibility of the RNC to win
elections right that that's though
that's the they're not supposed to help
Republicans win elections that's the
whole reason for them being
they have blown it what is the RN and I
know that you don't know yourself
personally uh you're a member of
Congress I'm not trying to put the onus
on you to answer for them but unless the
RNC decides that they want to do the
things necessary to support candidates
and win and really do those things
they're not going to win and it looks to
me going judging by the last election
that they aren't they don't have smart
people
strategizing to win that actually are
aware of what the Democrats are doing
it's it's plain to see what the
Democrats are doing they don't hide
their their philosophies they don't hide
their goals they don't hide their
strategies
so why is that nobody in the RNC knows
what they wrote an article yeah Shadow
campaign save the election where they
break down they're like we had a voter
in the park and we got Universal mail-in
voting and we went door to door and we
were ballot chasing and we were doing
all these things all made legal by our
allies in our courts it's like
maybe maybe the real investment
opportunity is the libertarian party
with um the mises caucus
you know you've got
um tremendous growth in that in that
area and Millennials and gen Z I think a
third consider themselves to be
independent or
um more than a third they they favor
neither party
and so
I I really do think the biggest mistake
the Republicans made was re-electing
Ronald McDaniel it shows they're
completely out of touch and
look man
I grew up in Chicago
you know Chicago Urban liberal type I
voted for Donald Trump and Republicans
in 2020 because his policy was more in
line with everything I've been talking
about and agreed with so it would be
insane not to
but I want to win you know and and in in
2022 seeing despite the fact that you
can look at all the polls and see the
the the it's not a silent majority it's
a vocal majority that are saying things
like the economy is bad it was it was
years of conversations about high gas
prices about food shortages the famous
mayonnaise gate story where the left
attacked a local restaurateur because he
said he was spending like 200 bucks a
week in mayonnaise and he was like yeah
I have a 250 person capacity restaurant
were typically full and we use
mayonnaise for dressings and for
sandwiches and for dips and they
insulted the guy and called him far
right for simply saying mayonnaise was
expensive and I'm just like
after all of that it's because
mayonnaise is white that's probably why
but it's just like it's it's I I called
the restaurant I talked to the guy and
he's like this is crazy I've talked
spoken to so many regular people across
the board and it seems like the
sentiment is all in line more with the
Republican party but the Republican
party is run by incompetent people and
so I'm kind of thinking yeah I'd like
Trump to win but I'd also prefer winning
so maybe if we can't win in 2024 because
of like you look how bad it was in 2022.
2020 and 2022
then it's like okay maybe instead of
investing all of our time and energy
into 2024 with a split party that's
fighting amongst itself over whether or
not Trump should even be the nominee
over whether or not ballot harvesting
was the problem in the first place over
whether or not Trump won or didn't win
I'll just put all the resources in the
libertarian party maybe we'll knock him
up a few a few percentage points this
time around so that by 2032 maybe
they'll have enough points got a debate
stage with the national debate
commission or something
because otherwise I'm like right now I
do believe based on the track record of
Economics Trump is on track to win
because Biden they can't but if they
bring in Michelle Obama
I think it's a strong possibility
Michelle Obama wins I think it's a way I
think it's more than a strong
possibility I think it's slam dunk
really really probably right because you
combine everything we've already talked
about with the the mechanisms they've
created to win with Michelle Obama as
celebrity Personality yeah probably I
don't I I think that even if if Biden
announces he's not running and they
field Michelle I think there are enough
strong Democrat candidates that will
make her look foolish in terms of actual
policy right like she may have the
celebrity and she was the first lady but
she doesn't I mean what she was a lawyer
at one point like she hasn't been
practicing in the field for a long time
I honestly think Gavin Newsom would be
able to get the nomination over her and
I think Gala Newsome is crazy I also
think aesthetically he is not what uh
the Democratic party wants I think that
it's easy to be frustrated I'm not
saying that you're wrong to say that you
know there are all kinds of things that
the Republican Party should be doing and
I am very interested in the future of
the libertarian party but I think that
the voting base does believe in Trump
even if the leadership doesn't I think
that you will see people wanting him to
win and even if the party doesn't do
things they should I think ultimately
it's dying anyways like yes they put Ron
McDaniels back in but I don't think
she'll win again I think that they are
seeing the tides turn I don't think that
they will be able to continue to squeak
by on the little confidence that the
voters have on them if they aren't
willing to get behind their preferred
candidate
yep
I don't know Trump needs to win well
I'll I'll finish it with this 74 million
votes Donald Trump got 74 Mary Wells
he'll get 74 75 million votes in 2024
and he'll win with that Joe Biden ended
up with 81 million votes it's because
the universal ballot and they all use
covet as the excuse we will not have
covet now to just send ballots to
everybody and everybody's brother and
have no accountability so Donald Trump
will be the 47th president with 75
million votes so one thing covet
loopholes I I I love the sentiment I
love the Prospect and I hope but one
thing that needs to be considered by the
Republican party is that it is 2023. it
has been uh quite some time since Donald
Trump was elected I think it's it's not
it's been about six six years in a few
months since the 2016 election but the
Donald Trump election cycle was 2015
talks of it
um some campaigning I think he did a lot
of campaign in 2015 right and then 2016
was the primaries
I'm sorry 2016 was the actual um full
presidential campaign so uh somebody who
was 10 years old
in 2015. whose mother was crying
watching TV will be voting this time
around
and and there's going to be a bunch of
kids who are around that age who are
young pre-teens whose entire world view
is crafted upon orange Hitler and they
will be voting this time around as well
Tick Tock has radicalized them other
social media platforms are radicalizing
them so I think uh if it's Michelle
Obama it might end up being 90 100
million because you combine the fact
that they're going to have a brainwashed
youth base with their ballot harvesting
mechanisms and other Outreach programs
yeah Donald Trump might actually get 80
million this time around I think so
because a lot of older people but uh
I you you've got to take consideration
the changing demographics there's going
to be less Boomer voters because they're
aging out as it were and there's going
to be more gen Z and Millennial voters
who are typically or at least large
numbers
crazy
putting it lightly I don't want to swear
but yeah out of their minds I mean
we had somebody on the show vosh I asked
him about
you know Biden in in 2012 and like the
the collapse and stuff and he says I
don't know I was in high school I don't
have no idea what happened he just
starts talking about horse penises
did he that's that's a vosh joke the
internet will understand I'm sorry no
just uh he's he was like I'm he's like
I'm 26. I don't remember Joe Biden and
I'm like oh so these these people don't
even know anything about them who knows
who they'll run no idea could be AOC I
mean it really could I think they'll
have a really hectic year I mean I don't
know how you feel about it but I just
think that there is no clear Foreigner I
think Biden is making it worse for them
by the fact that he doesn't want to step
down I also think that the D Triple C is
already having a hard time because they
want to move where they're having their
first primaries and it's already
dividing the party uh by the states
right I mean New Hampshire is saying
that they will not give up their first
first the nation primary I mean this
party is in chaos we just feel we're
used to them being like this so it
doesn't seem like it they they can't
they don't have a front FrontRunner
nominee and they don't know where
they're having primaries I mean that's
bizarre
well again he got 74 million votes and I
think uh when the average person looks
at Joe Biden and Donald Trump and his
successes and when you look at his
success with the minority communities
the opportunity zones that he created
the uh unemployment rates among minority
groups and everybody I mean our country
was on cruise control it was the safest
I mean our Global Security I mean we
didn't have all these issues with with
Little Rocket Man teasing South Korea he
kept Putin in check never went into
Ukraine under Trump went in and took
Crimea in 2014 and then goes under uh
goes back in the Ukraine under this uh
the week President we have today and
then he did a good job with Gigi pink
keeping him and not toying with Taiwan
so I think if if if you have a a half a
brain and you're concerned about this
country and the direction it's going and
and I I can't see how you could not vote
for Donald Trump but listen here's
you're right but think of it this way
there is a smart man and woman and
they're at the grocery store and they're
looking at the ingredients because
they're concerned about the amount of
sugars and preservatives and you walk up
to him and say quick question you vote
for Donald Trump and they go hmm I might
convince me and then you talk to them
for a few minutes and ago you make some
good points I'll consider it then the
Democrat walks up to two people who are
buying ho-hos and Ding Dongs and they're
like yo my dude high five and then they
vote for Biden good luck I think that's
why they want this perp walk photo so
badly right like this is why they wanted
handcuffs so anyone who comes to collect
violence can be like well that's why 90.
Hannah 90 electric they know who they're
voting for before they know who they're
voting for today it's at 10 it's those
Independents that we have to focus on we
didn't do very well Tim I'm going to
agree we didn't do very well in in 2022
with them but something's got to change
for 23. but actually uh Republicans did
do well but Democrats ballot harvested
yeah well again uh we got to do better
with The Independents though as well so
I I listen do I have an answer all this
I just don't believe that that you're
going to see all these ballots Donald
Trump had 74 million voters the most
votes ever in a presidential election in
the history of our country and all of a
sudden Joe Biden gets 81 Million by
sitting in his in his basement by
sitting in his basement you could say it
was ballot harvesting I think there was
some okay ballot harvesting but I
believe there was some uh from fraud and
governors and secretaries of state and
County clerks and others abused at
secretaries of State they abused the the
election laws in their individual states
under the color of coven because of the
national declaration it was an emergency
so we had to make these decisions these
governors in some of these states never
even called their legislatures back they
didn't have to because they're in the
state of Texas a good example Governor
Abba could do what he wanted
unilaterally he didn't have to get his
he didn't have to call back his State
Legislature his state senators and
representatives because it was under an
emergency declaration and that's what
Governors did in many of these liberal
states or these moderate States they
they abused and those policies have all
been codified outside of the emergency
provisions and still exist to this day
and will be used again
yeah so
that's why if the Republicans don't
figure out that this is all within the
confines that is all within the law it's
been codified legislatures have signed
them sealed it stamped it and it's good
they're going to lose Donald Trump got
more uh votes than any incumbent in a
re-election
and then Joe Biden got more and what I
told Steve Bannon was it's because
Donald Trump was anti-elected nobody was
voting for Joe Biden they were voting
against Trump
people kept looking at the polls and I
would see Trump supporters be like
enthusiasm for Biden is 26 Trump can't
lose and then I would look at the poll
and it would say enthusiasm against
Trump was 96 enthusiasm for Trump was 94
and I'm like that's your metric Atlantic
wrote the article I talked about a lot
stay alive Joe Biden all we need is your
corporeal form they were saying in plain
plain earshot of every single person we
don't care about Joe Biden no one is
actually voting for him we are voting
his name because we don't want Trump
that's what they were doing
so now they have the mechanisms to do it
again and the Republicans are fighting
with themselves or maintaining
incompetent leadership I mean do you
think that Democrats really would vote
for Biden again do you think they'll
just fall in line because he is not
doing well he's not popular It Well it
can't be Biden but using these same
mechanisms if like look Donald Trump
said it that's all that matters all
right Donald Trump believes it and he's
right ballot harvesting we have to
become masters of ballot harvesting and
Donald Trump said something that effect
because he understands and I'm glad he
does and that gives me some confidence
that their Republican party or at least
Donald Trump is paying attention to what
exactly happened because the spending
spending years talking about dominion
and China and all this stuff and German
servers and fraud was not solving the
problem Donald Trump and that's why last
year I was like I'm probably for
DeSantis at this point because he's
effective he's doing these great things
and all Donald Trump was talking about
was fraud fraud fraud you will never win
an elected if that's all you do now
Donald Trump is he's back he's calling
out the BS he went to East Palestine he
bought McDonald's for First Responders a
very human thing to do I loved it and he
talked about ballot harvesting and how
we've got it we got to do this to win
and I'm like we got strategy we got
energy we got real campaign work going
on this guy's got to win yeah I think
it's the energy it and Phil I don't know
I talk to a lot of people and just kind
of ask about Donald Trump and I said
what don't you like about him and I've
never had anybody ever come up and say I
didn't like this certain policy
it was all personal 100 yeah it was like
well I I don't like what he said about
John McCain I don't like he's he's a
shrew he's rude again I talked you know
a narcissist and all stuff and I'm
thinking to myself but how does that
affect you every day what affects you
every day are the policies and the
results with the inflation and the fuel
and our economy was thriving isn't that
more important but people just kind of
look at it and say I just don't like him
and if that is the mindset today that I
just you know he had we had a great
country under Donald Trump
and and he's coming back he's the only
guy in my humble opinion that can save
this country he's the only guy that can
save this country uh I I have saddled my
horse I just believe that Donald Trump
is the leader of the Republican party to
Santa seems like he's a nice guy but he
blew it the other day and I just hope
and pray I tell you Tim uh we can't
afford four more years of of Joe Biden
or any other Democrat we just can't
afford four more years you think you
have you're going to have four different
sets of bathrooms you're going to have
COA everything swim teams man women
doing this doing that transgender
everything we're going to get rid of
your truck if you have a diesel out
there tow it out of this lot because
get rid of it can't have it uh and and
so our country is going off a cliff and
if the American people can't see that
it's right in front of their face the
Republicans we got to wake up we have to
wake up because this has been coming
this has been in front of us and we have
completely I don't know ignored it or we
just think it wasn't important but we
have to wake up and we got to save our
country we're going to go to super chats
but I do want to continue that
conversation in the members only portion
and then bring in our good friends who
are hanging out in the Tim cast members
Discord to talk about the election and
what's going on as well so we'd love to
hear from your questions so become a
member at timcast.com so that means
don't not on YouTube because it means go
to timcast.com the website click join us
there's a Discord uh uh button in the
menu that will explain to you how to
sign up and get in and then you can join
uh there's read the rules and understand
if you're a 10 a month member for at
least six months you get access to the
voice room if you want to immediately
just jump the line 25 bucks a month
understand we have to do some kind of
gating either time gate or money gate to
keep out Bad actors we're going to try
and get everything shut down so it is
what it is but I think it'll be great to
bring in some um some questions from the
from the audience on this one but let's
read super chats so also smash that like
button and let's read
all right cold Deluxe production says
the struggle of today is not all
together for today it is for a vast
future also Abraham Lincoln annual
message to Congress December 3rd 1861.
yeah yeah
all right let's see uh sketch therapy
says I'm canceling my membership
um f open chat I paid to avoid open chat
you said you wouldn't have to deal with
these trolls
so what we've done is instead of being a
YouTube member you could become a member
at timcast.com and join the Discord
where we have a screening process so
that and rules so you can avoid all of
that stuff so instead of having to spend
10 bucks there and five bucks here it's
the same 10 bucks now getting you access
so we've we've centralized it all to
save you money to hopefully so so yes if
you are unhappy with the the reopening
of the YouTube chat then just use your
website membership or join the website
and you can go into the exclusive 24 7
conversation talking about news and
stuff I was in there earlier today post
some breaking news and we're gonna get
the timcast crew in there periodically I
think some of our writers were actually
just hanging out talking to people it
was kind of fun people posted memes
all right
Jonathan e says the 15-minute City
Chicken Coop guy is former Ontario MPP
Randy Hillier who along with Maxine uh
Maxim Bernier and Derek Sloan was among
the few connect politicians to oppose
faucism randy'd be a great guest I agree
it was funny do you know what a
15-minute city is no they are proposing
these uh in the future you'll all live
in a 15-minute City where everything you
need is within 15 minutes of you and you
won't need to go anywhere or do anything
because it's all right there this guy
made a funny video where he was like I'd
like to show you an example of how a
15-minute City would work and then he
opens a chicken coop and he's like all
of their food is here their water it's
warm and safe there's no reason to leave
they can leave if they want but they
don't want to and then I can go over and
start grabbing the rags and take what
they produce see they own nothing and
they're happy
yep they treat us like chickens
all right
yeah but Trump says so this one time on
band camp I made these songs they
decided I wasn't woke enough and they
deleted my account and the content they
also deleted I believe Bryson gray in
five times August now here's the thing
if you're gonna make enough if none of
these accounts should have been deleted
but the songs we had up the lyrics are
like you know uh will the will of the
people is a story about a revolution
there's no one being named there's no
there's a political message on
revolutions and that was it
you know I wish I could find the way to
restore peace blessed were the days we
held in vain like they banned that so
that's what I'll tell you this
to everybody
who uh when I played the clip at the
beginning of the show I saw people being
like you know it's emo and I people
criticizing it you know let me just tell
you something first and foremost
I've been playing music my whole life
you don't have to like it you're allowed
not to and then I will also say we are
building we are trying to do things that
are impacting culture and all three
songs we've released have charted on
Billboard that's a 100 success rate so
far
that's bigger than many mainstream major
label bands major labels sign these big
artists put them on tours spend millions
of dollars and they might get one or two
to actually chart we've done three for
three and we haven't spent that much
money
if we can do things like this and it
succeeds and we make money we expand
imagine what we can do when we actually
start bringing in new artists signing
more people and grow that portion of the
business for the time being we are
spending very little in making very
little
but having tremendous success hopefully
this will be song number four to chart
on Billboard in its first release week I
think it will if you guys support us and
then uh we got a video game coming out
I'm also going to say this too
we have the elite club at timcast.com
and a lot of people are shocked it's 100
bucks a month and you get access to the
elite club Discord but we are also I I
don't want to speak too much about what
goes on behind the scenes but I will
just say many of the people uh we're
planning on giving elite club members
direct access to Alpha test beta test
pre-releases access I I don't want to
say too much because I might freak
people out who work here but we need
play testers we need uh uh you know
things like that and so we're thinking
that's probably the best way to do it
the elite club so you know if you're
interested we got a video game it's
really fun and we've teamed up with
freedom tunes for it's basically a
freedom Tunes video game that we are
putting all the work behind and it's
Freedom Tunes themed art and everything
so I'm really excited for that shout out
to Seamus Coughlin
all right let's grab some more Super
chats
all right
cam girl Asuna says if Trump gets
arrested it will be proof that our
country has truly fallen it will prove
the institutions can no longer be
counted on to resolve these differences
we will have one choice left to have
freedom Civil War yikes
I hope not man
but um
we'll talk about that in the members
only portion because I do kind of feel
like I don't know if we have any uh I
don't know if there's a choice
Aaron says DeSantis is a traitor I voted
for him and I live in Florida
wow those are strong words man it was
very strong words
Chris pavoto says to the Texas rep I
sent you and 47 other Texas reps a very
detailed letter about Down syndrome and
Texas Medicare support without your
office responding on your advice last
time on IRL why the silence except those
with the D next to their their name look
it up sent July 2022.
don't know
all right where are we at
Bobcat says buy chickens and collect the
government that was a very very good
video I really do like it
T-Rex Pet Shop says my main Twitter
account got suspended a while ago so
couldn't create account for T-Rex Pet
Shop I messaged Ian on his website minds
and Instagram he can email and text or
call us from the website directly let's
work together
we will uh well let's try and put a
reminder for uh for Ian yep we keep
trying to reach out to you
we'll get to it I promise
all right
msk gwd says orange wave 2024 Trump
Bitcoin having two forces of nature that
can't be stopped that is very
interesting Bitcoin allegedly uh
reportedly gonna hit a million bucks in
a few months and Bitcoin is you know
like the orange pill that's what Max
Kaiser calls it Donald Trump is the
orange man maybe we will have a a fusion
of the crypto and Trump economy and you
know there you go my fake Instagram
profile tell you all about it
still giving out crypto advice Instagram
won't take it down
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim honestly
do you really think normy's given ish if
Trump gets arrested they never cared
about anything but sports ball and
celebrities yeah normies probably don't
but the moderates that the Republicans
need to win it's going to light a fire
under them like
I've talked to a lot of people a lot of
people who were not conservative of
voted for Trump were the stop making me
defend Trump camp where it's like you're
lying about him what's wrong with you
and then being like you know what
Trump's not that bad take someone like
that and play a video of trump getting
arrested and they're gonna be like this
is going too far
these people have lost their minds they
need to be stopped
are you gonna vote for Trump
all right
what do we got the great treasure says I
watch every day love the show and all
you're doing to grow great guest keep up
the great work Tim and team you should
have Ray Comfort on this channel on our
new Friday show stay strong keep the
faith and stay focused we'll do
Colorado says AOC would counter Trump
after the first debate by coming out
tassels spinning on a pole
[Music]
[Laughter]
I don't I don't I I don't know if I find
that one as funny I mean if they if they
made a comment about something more
related to aoc's character and
personality things she does and you know
I just wasn't expecting it don't call me
off
the prize was good like if she came out
and you know
easy I tried to imagine what she would
do no I mean like if if you wanted to
like to make a joke about what her
behavior would be like on the on the
debate stage it would be like doing a
sassy Latino Voice or saying something
in Spanish like yeah probably not that
out of the ordinary I mean yeah
she runs but Alex Stein as her press
secretary
no that's something that she comes up
into Alex Stein T-shirt oh my goodness
that would make his life
monk in training says Michelle isn't a
political figure she won't run she hates
the White House and politics she won't
run
perhaps that has nothing to do with
whether or not she'd win
true yeah
all right uh one individual BS is asking
why you aren't bringing impeachment to
the floor daily
daily may be a bit hyperbolic but uh
what's your view on impeachment well
number one I don't know what uh what
purpose it serves I think that she is
worse than he uh I don't think Kamala
Harris is ready for that uh he is an
absolute failure Joe Biden is a failure
I don't support him in any form or
fashion but again I got to make the
comment I want him to be the nominee
that's a good point I just I don't want
him impeached you you will not see me
file uh articles of impeachment on Joe
Biden because I want him to be the
nominee for the Democrats in 2024. I
think Kamala Harris is a dismal failure
she broke the glass ceiling but she
can't put a you know a sentence together
and and you can see the Democrats what
they've done they've kind of pushed her
to the side and they've kind of hit her
they don't want her out front anymore
because she's embarrassing quite
honestly so that that that's a fantastic
answer because you know I'm like Joe
Biden should be impeached but now I'm
not so sure no no no no no we need to
keep him right where he's at send them
get your people send them 25 because we
want him to be the nominee it's like
Michael malice talking about fetterman
like uh maybe the weakest flailing
Goddard is the guy you want in because
he's the guy Trump's gonna you know
win against because because if he's not
there then maybe it is Michelle I don't
know what do you think we'll hear from
Biden on what his plans are for he said
he already said he's running he said
he's running but they haven't really
a formally announced I mean they keep
sort of saying he will but then they're
like oh he's going to make a decision
he's going to talk to Jill I think
there's a certain amount uh there's a
certain amount of Democrats that don't
want to see Joe Biden run for
re-election because they want someone
else maybe they want to start fresh
start new so some of these
investigations that we're conducting
they actually want to see us come up
with some good evidence to force him
they want us to come up with some stuff
on Hunter and get enough probable cause
so to speak that that will expose that
family for who they truly are to put
enough pressure on Joe Biden to get him
out of the race and so there there is
there's a certain group of those
Democrats that enjoy what's happening
right now with Jim Jordan and comer on
these investigations with the Biden
family because they want us to take it
to the point where Joe Biden will just
he will have to uh he he won't be able
to seek re-election because he's been
damaged by the Republicans and there's
Democrats at once and they don't have to
do it themselves I mean they're letting
you do the work that's right you know
I'm thinking about it there's I I want
Trump to win but I I really really want
a three-way debate with Joe Biden Donald
Trump and Dave Smith
yeah I I just think that would be
absolutely fantastic I think amazing
television I think Dave would go hard on
on he would he would go after Trump
pretty well
Trump would respond pretty well I think
Biden would be just which is destroyed
it would be like
you know because because Dave's going to
talk to Trump about foreign policy and
he's going to say with all due respect
these things these things and Trump's
going to say you don't understand with
this that and Biden's going to be like
and then they're both going to turn and
look at him and be alike now let's talk
about you and then it's just going to be
I think it would honestly make people
uncomfortable to watch because I think
they would be able to verbally
outmaneuver Biden so easily and then
obviously intellectually like totally
different level people are gonna watch
him be like he's just getting wrecked
it's like when you watch one of those
WWE fights and there's like an older
fighter who's retiring and like he gets
beaten up really bad and you're sort of
like I don't I don't really like this
Elders should step out look elder abuse
is my Kink so I kind of like the idea
but uh don't go home
but I I I can't think of anything more
enjoyable to do watching TV than watch
ing Trump beat the crap out of out of
tapioca brain Joe pudding Joe pudding
Sorry God Jay girl says not cheating
it's optimizing used by consultants and
Tech workers in their corporate work
Republicans just have Tech illiterate
campaign runners
uh to that something that effect like
the the the the ACT blue win red thing
was shocking to me when I found that out
I was like how do you run the second
biggest political party and not have a
tech division running digital
fundraising for you it's crazy to me
but you know here's what it is
all right let's see we got
MF Damian says voting for party regards
of candidate quality is the slow growing
terminal cancer that's got us to this
point stop rewarding it yeah but that's
why you know some people have liked to
the Libertarians tell me like you can't
vote for Trump gets the lesser of two
evils you got to change the thing in
vote Libertarians and I'm like nah dude
that argument worked like in 2008 and
2012 but then we got Trump
and Trump's not the lesser of two evils
Trump's actually okay pretty good in
some ways best foreign policy of My Life
um and anybody says otherwise is lying
Abraham Accords right Afghanistan
withdrawal plans not implementation
Biden screwed that up the the
negotiation with Kim Jong-un was was
historic
it's insane to me I mean it was
absolutely fantastic and the economy was
great so lesser of two evils I'm like
this guy was standing up for this
country he was securing its borders
bringing jobs back he was saying he was
doing good work for the union for the
Union Middle Class guys he was doing
good on foreign policy how is that evil
other than like he wasn't doing enough
to immediately end the Foreign Wars he
was winding them down and how could the
former Speaker of the House publicly
state that he couldn't support Donald
Trump in November because he's evil
think about that now he's the former
speaker of the house not too long ago I
I don't I don't trust those people yeah
I think I think they're power hungry
evil elitist authoritarians and I think
Donald Trump is narcissistic and uh
arrogance that's an understatement but I
think he knows what he wants I think he
does like helping people I think he does
want to fix America I think he does love
this country I think he's got some
character their defects again
understatement but it's like do you want
the guy who's
got Character defects and kind of sounds
nasty but makes the machine run it's
like the way I described it a few years
ago is you can hire the plumber who
doesn't know what he's doing and is
confused the whole time or the plumber
who's one of the best in the business
but he won't stop cussing up a storm in
your bathroom
I got to be honest I'll take the guy
who's cussing because he's going to fix
the pipes I don't want crap flying all
over the place I'm not gonna call the
other company where the guy can't fix
the plumbing because he's nice to me you
know nice is good but and Trump is a
nice guy if you're nice to him that's
that's the reality
I've I've heard too many stories of
trump being a good good person to other
people and he's only mean when people
are mean to him my wife I had an
opportunity to take my wife down a visit
with him and uh you know she didn't like
some of his you know his comments and
thought he was somewhat rude and I said
well babies from New York and he's a
he's a very successful businessman but
after she had an opportunity to engage
with him and meet him she had a
different take on him and and and I I've
said it several times I don't know of a
guy that that loves this country more
than he does he puts the American people
first and that's what I'm looking for
I'm like listen we're a great country we
we've we've done so well we're the
greatest country in the world we've
helped others but I'm telling you right
now what about taking care of the
American people first before we just
start throwing billions of dollars into
Ukraine what about our own Southern
border what about the homelessness what
about the mental illness that we have in
this country what about the crime in
this country but we're more concerned
about spending billions and Bill
millions of dollars and sending it to
Ukraine in a war that Acquire I can't
really understand the the administration
here doesn't even have a real strategy
as it relates to Ukraine and that's just
going to get ugly it's going to get ugly
to him because the negotiation he's
going to want Crimea back
he's zelinski is going to want Crimea
back it's not happening
yeah all right the Tennessee tornado
says agreed the Democrats are a cult but
how is turning on someone because they
won't kiss Trump's ass not also a cult I
agree with you that's why I've said
there's a trump cult for sure a lot of
people who are like crazy Trump's
burning DeSantis Flags I'm like yo
that's weird but there's not that many
of them it's like Five Guys status at a
Trump Tower waving flags and they have
there's some with an online presence
there's a few there's probably tens of
thousands maybe but if we're talking
about 74 million Trump voters these are
regular people that's it the Democrats
you got to be nuts to vote for Joe Biden
you got to be mindless zombies to vote
for that guy you have for Trump to have
gained 12 million votes that means
people had to actively resist the
corporate press and learn something for
themselves and say you know what I gotta
vote for this guy that's not a cult
yeah but the media is going to keep
lying so
all right Kenny cab says put ballot
boxes in churches nursing homes and gun
ranges right there
there's the gun ranges that's a good one
I like that
all right where we go we got
uh let's see
let's see where we at
uh
I'm trying to read this one Tim's
finding super chats can you tell us
about the uh pilot legislation that
you're working on right now I think it's
kind of interesting because so many
people especially going to Spring and
everything are traveling and are
experiencing the problems with like the
travel the airline issues yeah and I
serve on the transportation
infrastructure committee and I'm the
chairman over pipelines or hazardous
material pipelines and rails oh wow so
kind of interesting yeah I've been to
I've been to East Palestine uh before
but uh right now there's a shortage of
Pilots obviously if we fly a lot
obviously there's a shortage of pilots
and the current law is Once you turn 65
you can no longer fly the big the big
Airlines
so what we're trying to do is create
have legislation to take it from 65 to
67 which just makes sense I I can't see
now now the Alpa which is the big Union
for many of these big Airline Airlines
they're against it but I I just think it
makes sense that I think we're gonna
we're getting some momentum we got some
Senators over there that are drafted
their own legislation very similar to my
legislation and I think we're going to
get this through because it just makes
sense what is what's the Union's reason
for being against it well they really
don't they say that they have a data
scientific data that says that going 65
to 67 could be related to health issues
but these same Pilots are going through
they're taking their EKGs they go
through vigorous physical assessments
and and health assessments so I just
think maybe it's because you know these
guys up at the top that have been there
for 30 years are probably holding their
slot you know and they want that slot
they want that that seniority so maybe
they could get the the better flights
and have you know and choose what they
want to do and where they want to fly so
I it makes no sense to me and I've had a
lot of them inside my office over the
last couple weeks and these guys I tell
you you look at them you want those guys
in the cockpit oh oh I'm sorry let me
rephrase it's not a cockpit it's a
flight deck it's a flight deck I can't
say cockpit because that's offense so
it's in it's in the flight deck and I
want the most experienced qualified
person in that flight deck uh and and
and there's a lot of guys in there is
offensive oh yeah well he feminizing
called say crewman either what if we
what if I would not say crewman if it's
if it's offensive because cockpit is
masculine what if we made it feminine
like snizzle
this is how silly this is getting uh
this is how silly this is getting what
we're having to change words cockpit and
and you can't say crewman anymore and
now it's crew perfect I mean it's just
getting absolutely I know you know
people flight attendant that was the
first people get mad at us because we
have cocktown you know right roosters
that's the technical term right it is a
it is a scientific reference it is a
town full of but that's the
legislation it'll be good for the
airline industry and we're going to get
it done why did they pick 65 it was just
well they changed it they changed it
from 60 to 65. it was 60. okay the
change is 65. we just want to take it to
67.
all right Patrick C says Tim you forgot
about Gen X we have an aged out to die
LOL and most of us are very
right-leaning I didn't forget it's we
just don't think about you it's just not
relevant to bring up because you're not
dying that's the point your votes are
still there boomers are relevant to the
conversation because many of them are
dying retiring or just not voting gen
xers are there voting but Millennials
and gen Z are crazy you see it was a
compliment without referencing you I was
pointing out that we don't need to worry
about gen Z because y'all are doing all
right but Millennials and gen Z are nuts
so well I mean I think most people who
watch the show are actually Millennials
so we're doing all right I guess so I
appreciate that so we'll we'll we'll
we'll got to get it done
all right
Max Morano says as a business owner I
work for over 150 aesthetic medical
practices across the country the
affluent are not spending money if
they're rich or not spending the poor
are not spending I have way more insight
and would like to speak with you about
this call or email
let me just say that um looking at all
of the um add spending like I think the
economy is about to collapse very very
very much so because I'm looking at our
numbers and looking at what BuzzFeed
reported I think even Vice media is in
the verge of collapse like outright
total just bankruptcy that's the I
didn't even know I didn't even see this
like last month advice is talking about
going bankrupt or something like that
bankrupt Vice five years ago six years
ago they were like worth five six
billion dollars bankrupt yeah it's
getting bad
how fast can you think yeah we'll see I
mean we're like we're we're doing fine
financially I guess
um if we want to expand like we need to
bring on you know more members and stuff
like that but uh
I don't know if it does get
substantially worse I'm talking like
double triple then we'll be in trouble
and we're doing better than BuzzFeed and
you know ad rates are down but that's
why we shifted to a membership based uh
company so if you want to see us uh keep
doing this then become a member at
timcast.com smash that like button uh
support the show we're we have set up
the Discord Channel
and um as an aside I also have been like
talk I texted the the CEO of Rumble I
was like guys you need to make
your own version of Discord because like
you know but anyway uh become a member
go to timcast.com click join us sign up
if you want to get into the VIP voice
chat immediately then it's 25 bucks a
month
we're and we're setting it up so that
after like six months you can drop back
down to ten we just have to create some
kind of gate to keep out Bad actors so
there's a lounge in the VIP lounge and
that's either six months as a member or
25 bucks a month and then we take
submissions for questions so we'll try
and do some call-ins tonight hopefully
it works out so again smash the like
button you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me at timcast
um I think we got suspended on Facebook
so there's more bad news for just
business revenue or whatever so and then
we've got uh other we're being sued
which uh we'll maybe we'll get into
um at some point but uh uh nails do you
want to shout anything out no I just I
again I appreciate you uh having me here
today and I appreciate you coming it's
been an absolute great conversation and
I just think it's you know uh we have
very trying times right now all the
conversation seems to be about Donald
Trump uh and and I'm glad that the uh
that the primary season it's it's upon
us now you're you're 12 months away from
having this primary and and I think we
just need to call let's get behind
behind Donald Trump
Governor DeSantis if you're listening
just get behind Donald Trump support him
let Donald save some of his money
because the real battle is going to be
in November let's come together and do
what we can to save this country period
right on cool
it's been great guys I'm Hannah Claire
I'm a writer for timcast.com you can
follow me personally on Twitter at HC
brimelow and you can follow me on
Instagram at hannahclar.b that's the end
of it you should definitely 110 follow
at timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
you can see work for me and all of our
other journalists and we're doing some
really cool on the ground stuff right
now with a lot so check that out thanks
guys
I am philibonti you can follow me on
Twitter at Phil that remains and on
Instagram I am at Phil that remains
official
and I am surge.com people ask me where
you can find the music it's at cool
contest records uh it's just a single
track
um appreciate it thank you good one uh
let's have uh people on the actual
Discord chat that are actually going to
leave voice chat like get ready for that
start going to it do it now because
we'll we will be able to make it work
today Tim so all right thanks for
hanging out everybody and we will see
you all over at timcast.com should be on
the front page in about seven minutes
thanks for hanging out we'll see you
there